ein ruhiger beharrlicher innerschweizer
ist in china die schlüsselfigur der
zeitgenössischen kunst
musik ist mehr als ein sommer in china
so heißt es immer wieder nennen ihn
manche künstler einen gott ich weiß
nicht ob sie ihn wirklich gott min
zumindest aber ist ein held wir haben
eine bronze büste für sie gegossen
uli sigg hat sein lebensprojekt
vollendet eine dokumentation des
heutigen china zu schaffen
eine sinnliche erforschung dieser welt
durch kunst seine sammlung ist
einzigartig weil er lange der einzige
war der überhaupt sammelte und das sehr
systematisch
für mich ist das die beste station zu
kino und das paar stunden hier maßstäbe
vielleicht haupttreiber produkte in bern
zeigen das zentrum paul klee und das
kunstmuseum gemeinsam die jüngeren
stücke seiner sammlung sigg hat künstler
in china entdeckt und im westen bekannt
gemacht der berühmteste von ihnen selbst
eine legende basics große einfluss kann
skeptisch machen
so ging es anfangs auch der kuratorin
der ausstellung kathleen bühler sich
aber sozusagen einfach sind wissen und
seine erfahrung und sein steter neugier
für die kunst liegt und hat das
akzeptiert und wie chrom und kaisern und
mehr hingegangen industrieberater für
die aufzugs firma schindler war er als
er erstmals nach china reiste das
erfahren wir nun in einem dokumentarfilm
den sf co produziert hat
regisseur michael schindhelm besucht mit
uli sigg die originalschauplätze jener
zeit als dieser die marktwirtschaft nach
china brachte sich handelte das erste
joint venture aus zwischen einem
chinesischen staatsbetrieb und einer
westlichen firma nebenbei stellte er
kontakte zur underground kunstszene her
und früh war klar
politik ist der west lade es schafft
sich in die mentalität der chinesin
einzufühlen und er ging beharrlich
seinen weg
dank grafischer geduld und empathie
man muss beides kein sichtbar noch
ansprechpartner und ich danke dir beide
elemente sind unschlagbar billig sie
dass es mir branche eigentlich guten rat
politik der ewige quereinsteiger
mitte der 90er jahre trug man die stelle
des schweizer botschafters in china an
und so nahm seine kunst mission rasch an
fahrt auf
die kunst osterbotschaft cryptic sie es
das sind konkrete sie sehr gute künstler
aber die sendung völliges unverständnis
stosse viele teenager die heckseite
extrem also eine schnelle chinesische
gewalt kunst mutet ihnen bringen
die schweizer botschaft als kunstmuseum
anfangs suchte der botschafter die werke
in abgelegenen hinterhöfen später nahmen
künstler selbst mit ihm kontakt auf
musik hat sie mit dem globalen
kunstbetrieb vernetzt heute sind viele
von ihnen erfolgreiche player auf dem
internationalen kunstmarkt im film
schwärmen alle von sich als visionär
mentor und freund den sie intern wurden
ich finde etwas eigentlich sehr guter
film betrifft klar richtig sein als eine
kundin
nun lädt er uns dazu ein nochmals in
seiner kunstsammlung einzutauchen
letztmals in europa dann geht der
löwenanteil nach hongkong
musik erfüllt seine mission und gibt in
einer großzügigen geste 1500 werke
zurück nach china wo keine vergleichbare
sammlung existiert nun entsteht dort ein
riesiger museumskomplex errichtet von
den basler architekten herzog & de
meuron und uli sigg kann sich mit seiner
frau überlegen wie er die
zurückbehaltenen kunstwerke aus china in
seinem schlösschen in der innerschweiz
verteilt